[Applause]
a minute remaining here in this third
period
lieutenant koopal throws it up shot
won't go gets the rebound back
up banks and a foul
ball punishing the subs here in the
third taking advantage of the size and
strength
gets the matchup he likes misses a shot
but continues
to attack the offensive boards this just
in
the freaks come out at night the greek
freak
having his way
[Applause]
drew holiday kicks it back out lopez
tucker finds it once again the slam
and brooklyn needs time out a multiple
pass sequence
holliday lopez tucker and then giannis
for the emphatic finish
and that's a learning play for giannis
too
oh block harry was right there and it
thrown right back in his face
[Applause]
the punctuation mark by the terrific
block
by adekupo and then the beautiful lob
as giannis runs to the rim
46 35
here is goddess
[Applause]
soaring high to put it down one dribble
after coming off that
high screen and roll with tucker and
just takes flight
at some point they're going to put a run
together very much like they did
in game three nice pass capella rejected
by under the combo by giannis
meet me at the summit details clint
capela
39 28.
[Applause]
middleton poor giannis
look at this beautiful lead pass here by
middleton
there's only one man in this building
that can get that and he got it
[Applause]
with all the physical play going on
doris
but giannis antenna
[Music]
slams at home and
[Applause]
hit by hill spins his way inside and
scores what a move
by not attacking that paint area
do you think this is going to be a dunk
and just switches it midair
right around clint capela
paul deflects it crowded averages
bridges
what a recovery for a guy with a hyper
extended knee
what a fantastic defensive play this is
reminiscent of lebron
james in cleveland against golden state
what an
effort incredible block
he only knows one way to play just
perfect timing
[Applause]
now booker with tucker on him throws
[Applause]
this is one of the great recovery plays
you'll ever see the log booker
to eight we've seen it many times and
that reaction
and block is special multiple effort
on the play stops the penetration of
booker doesn't give up
turns elevates blocks the layup attempt